[Music]
somebody sent me this note um so i want
to make sure i get to it's just an
important question
um
the questions from ashley and she writes
on
june 27th dr john said rest can be can
feel stressful
if busyness is how you medicate
uh and i think i may have posted that on
social media or reposted that from
somebody else maybe from my buddy ian
simkins but
she writes how do we do that nothing
i've tried helps me feel relaxed not a
beach trip not a massage exercise helps
my anxiety but it doesn't help me feel
relaxed
please elaborate
here's what i found and i've talked
about this recently on the show
if your identity
is in how busy you are
or if busyness doing doing doing doing
doing i've got another thing i got to
look at my list i got to make sure this
gets done if this doesn't get done i got
it all done i've done my things and i
got to go to these things once i get my
list done then i can go work on the
garden once i get the garden finish then
i
if that's your life
then rest then getting a massage going
to a beach and doing nothing will feel
like utter hell
your body it'd be like i drink
and even that's going to look great when
somebody clips that if you're somebody
who drinks after work
to feel better like or just to take the
edge off if you let's eat a drink after
a hard day
and you do that every day for a week and
then for a month and then you have a
hard day and you don't drink your body
will feel terrible it will feel terrible
and so we often think i'm just going to
go get a massage i'm just going to go to
the beach and lay on the beach for a
week
if busyness is how you deal with the
the pain in your life if busyness is an
identity if being busy and running and
gunning it go go go go i'm a ceo or i'm
a small business owner and then i run a
marathon on the weekend and then i've
got my kids and six different things if
that's you
then simply doing nothing will feel like
torture
so
um i think i mentioned this um i tried
that and by the way
this is me
this is me
busyness is my medication i don't do
drugs i don't i don't hardly drink at
all um
i
i'm busy and busy is my heroine it's my
numbing device
i just take on too many things i say yes
to everything and all right so that's my
that's my problem that i gotta work
through
um
so what i used to do is i would be so
busy until i was about to collapse and
then we'd go my wife and i'd go away for
two or three days because i was such a
cheapskate and um i couldn't roi a
vacation and so let's just go
and then i think i mentioned on the show
i would have a big crazy dinner because
we're finally on vacation and i'll have
a couple of drinks because we're finally
on vacation and then let's do something
in the morning and i'd be like no i'm
finally sleeping in
and then suddenly it's 11 30 or 12 the
next morning just watching episodes of
the office reruns on some hotel tv
and then i go eat again because the only
thing to pick up my blood sugar is
another meal and then
just within a couple of days i'm
exhausted i'm more exhausted i'm kind of
grumpy to be around and my body starts
itching
i'll start checking my work email i'll
start like trying like trying to do a
project that's down the road i just
start itching i got to do it got to do
this last time
um
my wife and i took a long vacation
and on that vacation i think i mentioned
this on the show
we were highly intentional about a
couple of things we exercised like crazy
um i took full advantage i saved my
money for weeks for months and um
i visited the spa several times like i
got several massages and i put the money
in to make sure i don't just we just got
money phone from this guy we're gonna
make sure that i've got time for this
because touch is important working it
all out is important
and we got out in nature a lot and then
we booked some we're gonna go do these
things together
and being with other people number one
she's my best friend on the planet she's
awesome
doing things together with hers is
enjoyable for me so that was number one
i had somebody else with me we had some
very clear things that we were not gonna
cancel
and i was moving my body i after day
three entered a state of rest that i
have not experienced ever in my that i
have any sort of recollection
the the last couple of days of this week
getaway um i had more important thinking
i had more peaceful thoughts i had more
hey i really need to work on this just
more clarity
and so those three things
if busyness is how you medicate
then when you get away
make sure you do it with somebody else
or other people that you have community
with
make sure you are exercising
do too much
what so not don't over do it and injure
yourself but make sure you're going to
go to the gym in the morning and sign up
for a yoga class we paid 10 bucks and we
went to just some rando yoga class in
the evening i did not want to go i did
not want to do that it was worth going
and then we went on another long hike
the next day and then i went back to the
gym later that evening right i just kept
i kind of pushed it pushed it pretty
hard
and then we had some appointments that
we didn't miss
and then we had one crazy get off the
rails meal it was awesome it was
ridiculous
and
uh but we ended up eating a lot more
sensibly throughout the week and it just
made us all feel better and we felt
better we were in better moods and we
were better moods we were able to rest
right
so that's what i'll tell you if you
struggle with busyness as a drug
you got to deal with the core issues
what are you running from what are you
running from what are you running from
so it's a great great question ashley
and i hope my answer helps um
i love these questions and you write
them in and i'll start doing a better
job of answering these email questions
we get some great ones in